foreign
today we will take you through a hands
of lab demo of the winner prediction of
the FIFA World Cup Qatar 2022 using
machine learning so we already did the
prediction where we took all the
countries which are playing in the FIFA
World Cup but this time we will predict
from the fourth semi-finalists which are
Argentina Croatia France or Morocco
okay so before we start I hope this
screen is clearly visible and the audio
is fine if yes please type in yes if
there are any issues do let us know in
the chat section so that we can resolve
them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
us the people join until then let me
tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek in a continuous hunt for
the latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply run
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through
some different questions regarding
football and solve them using different
function and libraries of python and
ultimately we will predict the winner of
FIFA World Cup 2022 from our fourth
semi-finalist okay so there is one
question for you guys which team do you
want to win the FIFA World Cup 2022 okay
Argentina Croatia France and Morocco
so comment down your favorite team in
FIFA World Cup so let's move to the
programming part
so first we will open up command prompt
to write a command to open Jupiter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
okay press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook okay and here you have to
select new python file
so this is the word kernel look likes
okay so here I will first change the
name
FIFA
you know
prediction
okay
give one space here okay
name it
so before that I want to
tell you guys that we have already read
the prediction
before that
okay
it's loading so this was the prediction
before we did
so you can check the
video in the YouTube on our channel so
this was the
prediction we did in which
we have predicted the
like top 10 goalskeeper score and
like top 10 is stronger defense
and the thing like top 10 attack score
so now what we will do we will do
with the only four teams which are four
semi-finalists okay that is Argentina
Croatia Morocco and plants so we have to
decide which team will we win okay we
have to predict so this is the top 15
teams with the highest win percentage
okay there is Argentina Croatia is there
Morocco is there you can see the France
is there
so from the previous prediction so the
winner was
Brazil okay as per the previous
prediction
but
this is just a prediction using machine
learning or the previous data okay
so now what we will do we will predict
from the only 14. okay we will just drop
all the data from our data set and we we
will create a new data
so yeah so we will remove all the teams
except
Argentina
Croatia Morocco and
France okay except that
so let's move
so this is our previous prediction you
can see the home TV advantage of like
Qatar and there are many
questions
like what is the winning percentage you
can check this link
okay you can check this video's link on
the description box below
and like do teams which is stronger
offensive players score more goals and
do teams with stronger goalkeeper like
this
and now we will cover this
question
okay for the
poor team
top 10 steam ratio considered calls
versus goalkeeper score this type of
question top 10 teams with longest win
streak
like better team win percentage
okay away team home team okay what is
the total so this type of question we
will
cover
so anyways this is just a prediction
okay
this is just a prediction so now we we
have four five same finalists now we
will predict
who will win the
FIFA World Cup Qatar 2022 using machine
learning okay
so we will take like logistic regression
here
okay so now let's import some major
libraries of python
for the analysis
so here we will report
date time
okay import
numpy
as NP
and B
so we will import
pandas as PD
and Airport matplotlib
dot Pi plot
TLD
graphics and all so here I will put C
bone
as SNS
and here I will import burning
okay then warnings
dot filter warnings
that is ignore
so let me run it yeah
so it's loading
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working within the domain
of lineal algebra
and matrices
it is a open source project and you can
use it freely okay so number stand for
numerical python and pandas panda is a
software Library written for the Python
programming languages for the data
manipulation
and the analysis in particular it offers
data structure
and operation for manipulating numerical
data set and the tables
okay then there is one more c bond
so c bond is a open source python
Library based on matplotlib it's called
C1 okay it is utilized for data
exploration and data visualization
with data frames and the pandas Library
c bond function with like ease
okay there is one more like matte
product lip so matte product lip for
Python and its numerical extension numpy
matte proclib is a cross platform data
visualization and like graphical
charting package
okay as a result it represents a strong
open source substitute for Matlab the
api's application programming interfaces
format product allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into GUI applications
okay date time one of the most often
used modules to modify data and the time
object data is known as the date time
okay you can read and convert date
strings at rate across the range of
dates and many more things okay so
moving forward let's import
the data set so you can download this
data set from the description box below
okay so I'm writing here DF equals to PD
dot read
underscore CSV
then data set name like new
international
underscore
matches
Dot
CSV
okay
then so then enter then I will do it
yes sorry my bad so DF
yeah so this is our data set you can see
here we have only Argentina Morocco and
Croatia France
okay
so what we will do now we will see how
many rows and columns are present so DF
shape I will write press enter
so as you can see let me do like this so
as you can see we have 758
a rows and 25 columns present in the
data set okay so then we will see some
information about the data set so for
that we have to add DF dot info
let's press enter
so as you can see you can see here home
team date away team home team continent
content City Country neutral location
shootout
these all are present in our data set
okay
foreign
okay so now let's see some static as
stats value so for that we have to write
DF Dot describe
okay
then here you can see some
count values are mean of the particular
column
then standard deviation then what is the
25 percent of this
you can say column like this we have
maximum value
we have things like this okay for all
the columns
okay so moving forward what we what we
will do we will change the date to
format date okay for that there's a
simple way to do it
was to PD Dot
to
date time
PF
date
okay press enter
so let's see the date
DF
so as you can see here date so before
that
yeah
so date is not a pro in a proper format
I guess yeah you can see it is not in
proper format so now you can see the
date in proper format okay
so moving forward
what we will do we will list all the
columns which contains
like none values and N values okay for
that I have to write columns
contains
okay that is column or call
ndf dot columns
if
like DF
column
dot is null
and
Dot
any
so what we will do we will print
columns contain
ER
okay like values
for the next line
so here I will write columns
contains
null
okay
so
so these are some columns contain null
values
okay
so what we will do we will import
team
okay which are the same final list
that is
Argentina
okay
then France
then
go
so spelling is wrong Morocco
then
there's one more Croatia
okay
uh
teams loaded we can write here like same
final steam
but it is okay like it's your wish to
what to write here okay so we'll make
one function
write a for Loop
30X in World Cup 2022
then for y in
columns
contain
against null
that is d f y
dot fill
Ane
that is DF
y
0 ratio nine
is equal to X
then why
dot mean
in place
equals to true
okay
so
it is done
so everything is done so we will do some
now Eda exploratory data analysis with
some charts and some values
so like I will take first question is
which team has the most win
so we will select the required columns I
need to and create a new data frame for
that okay so I will write home team
equals to
DF
date
comma
home team
comma
home team
score
comma
away
team score
okay we have we will create these new
four data frames
then right here home
underscore team Dot
Dot
okay
so we have created new home team home
team score
another team is scored and did okay
so like moving forward I will check for
all the home team that won their games
okay
whether it is Argentina whether it is
Morocco whether Croatia and France okay
so I will write here home
team
home team score
if you want this full code just comment
down below I will provide you like our
team will provide you
just come in for the same
way
team score
look at that
home wins
equals to
oh
team Dot
lock
then
let's go team
then
home
team score
then
home
underscore team
that will be away
team score
okay then we'll set home
which
okay let's see
so these are some team which
one
like the home team that won their games
okay
like somewhere at Utah in a home team
when he won from some team okay then
Morocco are about that crochets there
France is there for particular all the
rows okay
like they lose also because they have
only 483 Rose we have 700 something rows
okay they lose also that data is not
present here
so now I will check for all the away
teams that won their games not they've
won okay
or you can say like when they were will
be the away team okay
so I will check here home
team
score
home team
it's not here
foreign
sorry we are checking for the away team
away team
okay then home
those
who
home team
Dot
talk
home team
that is home
team
score
that is home
team
away
team score
okay so let's see the home loss home
loss for the four team
so as you can see the home team is
Argentina and the score is zero and our
team score is five
that is you can see France and these are
the the teams these four teams which
losses the game
okay the international matches
as a home team
they are only one zero five rows
Okay so
that mean two for the better visuals
so now what I will do I will merge the
both the tables okay so I will write
home team
pins
issue
four wins
it
comma
home team
comma
home team score
that comma
away team
score
okay
then
I will write here
I will write here uh
dot rename
columns
because you
oh
yeah so I will add a home team
that is
colon
okay A Team
comma home team
cool
hold on
you know it's good
obtain
and
okay then comma
set off away
team
or
have to write
away
team win
okay
so click next
so
it will go for the same awaiti means so
what I will do I will copy paste
all the things and paste it here
okay done
yeah
so now I will write here
team
Jake
because you
home team wins
but append
like way
team
wins
okay then
team
streak
why there is
team win
away team win
is there is one problem
string
let me run it now yeah
so as you can see we have four column
like team home team win private team win
okay
two times Argentina wins and await names
one being
like this okay so now we will check the
T mistake
which found the maximum time okay so
team
streak
team
dot value
counts
Dot and largest
one
okay now let's see the dream see as you
can see here the France is the team
which one like
which has a long history in team Street
okay 172.
so now we will see what is the winning
percentage comparing when the highest
ranked team is against the lowest ranked
team okay suppose if Argentina has the
highest ranked team and it is playing
against Morocco or some other team okay
lowest ranked team so what will be the
winning percentage
of the highest ranking to win the match
okay so then I will write
d f
victory
team one
comma team two
comma
team one
team one
let's go to rank comma
team two underscore rank
comma
team one underscore score
comma
team to underscore score
okay
and if
listen carefully if team one
score is greater than
team
to
score
okay then what will will happen winner
equals to T1
it's so simple
then as if
team one score
equals to equals to
team
two scores
okay
then winners
equals to
then winner equals to
okay Winner's spelling is wrong
is equal to drawn
yeah
then
else
winner
equals to
winner equals to team 2. got it
so it's a easy one
return
winner
okay
so let's imply some data frame JF
winners
go to DF Dot
apply
Lambda
X
victory
okay then
home team
way team
more X
form team
FIFA
rank
and
comma
we have to write X
away
team
FIFA
rank
comma X
home
team
score
X
away
team
score
okay then I will add access
equals to 1. X is equals to 1 means with
it will happen in column and X is equal
to 0 means row wise
okay
so then I have to write here I have to
create one function DF rank
ohm away
rank home
rank away
if rank
ohm
Bank away
and
go to the rank of it then
return
boom
okay
else
return
away
okay
and after I did d d f
like for better rank so
better
let's go rank
request you
have dot apply
Lambda
X
rank
right here like
X
then like for the home team
underscore team
then for the X
for the equity
the team
and for the X
team
FIFA
rank
X
V
team
and FIFA then rank
okay the axis will be same
comma axis
equals to column column means one
okay so then I have to write
DF
result
Bank
and
winner
I want pattern
rank
okay
then if Venus equals equals to
drawn
what will happen then
here equals to equal to drawn
then we'll Apple return
winner
okay
if winner
equals C equals to
better rank
what will happen return
there will be one column name highest
okay you will see in the graph
then else there is one option my red
return
policed
got it
so why do we need this
yeah
so
this
will write here DF then
result rank
equals to DF
Dot apply
Lambda
X
these are
tank
X
winner
comma
x for
better rank
comma
axis equals to 1.
okay
then I will run it then let's see the
graph
so PLT dot trigger
then figure size
should be
n comma 5
okay
total
was to float
end of DF okay
then ax equals to SNS Dot
count plots
x equals to
result rank
result rank
comma DF
like data equals to DF
okay
so I will run here for low for p in
a x dot
patches
percentage
equals to
1 f
okay until percentage
got it dot format
will you multiply by 100
into
P dot get
height
okay not here
I have to write more so I will
then I will run with
so
e dot get
bit
then hide
because you P Dot
get
height
and
X comma y
equals to P dot get
that X5
okay
so
ax ax Dot
a note
annotate
train
so percentage
comma like X
plus width will be divided by 2
and then
y Plus
height
is multiplied by
zero
okay
and h a equals to
Center
and pld in Dot sure
present
okay
dot it is not sound plot
so here you can see there will be high
chance of winning 63.1 percent
and there's a small chance of
losing okay drawn chances are 22.4
percent
okay
so now
the next question is like we will
predict what is the winning percentage
comparing when the highest attack rank
plays the lowest attack ranks okay in
previous we did the what is the winning
percentage of comparing when the highest
rank team plays against the lowest rank
team team okay so now we will predict
what is the winning percentage comparing
when the highest attack okay got it
attack rank plays the lowest attack rack
okay
so for that
Okay so
we'll delete this
so I will write here DF rank
back what's your
DF and DF again
home team
mean
and see if
score
dot not null
okay
then DF
rank
okay there is one problem home team
offensive score
offensive score it is
EF
rank
attack equals to DF
DF
away team
mean
fans
score
Dot
normal
okay
then
f
tank attack
so here I will write
to have
Bank
attack
on home comma away comma
drank home
come on okay
okay
then if
then come
back away
and
boom
okay
else
return
away
got it
so I will write here
so it's a long one let me copy the same
this better rank one
let's copy the same
hit here
okay
offense is good
so let me run it
delete input okay okay got it
score
so now it's working
okay let me copy this one
yeah and copy it from here
yeah so just just all change here
rank attack
result attack
let's show DF
rank attack
dot apply Lambda
Mr winner
on the battery X is equal to one okay
perfect
so now we will write a code
for the graph dot figure
then figure size should be
assume
10 comma 5
okay then total
is to float
then
and
of TF rank
attack
then x equals to
SNS Dot
count plot
then
x equals to
result
attack
comma
data so DF
tank attack
then for p in ax Dot
patches
and percentage
pursue
one
f
Dot
format
then
it
into p
dot get
height
right
time divided by total
okay
so width
equals to P dot get
width
then
that equals to
P Dot
get
height
then X comma
y equals to P Dot get
x y
then ax Dot
notate
page
comma
X
Plus
width
divided by 2
comma y
Plus
right it is height multiply by 1.02
comma h a equals to
Center
let's just go to this okay
then finally PLT Dot
show
okay this is
it's
it's
okay
63 14.5 it should be
different
air tank rack
check from the starting
okay it should be different
so TFT home team means offense score
.net
D mean offensive score okay okay it's
correct then rank attack
oh my way
that is okay
that is fine completely
guess
this
yeah
so as you can see
the winning percentage comparing when
the highest attack rank plays the lowest
attack rank is just for the highest
highest is 36 and the lowest is 40. okay
and the drawn will be 22.4
okay
so
what we will do
now
uh we will see the offense score
of the particular team
fans
score
and for X in
World Cup 2022
like which are the teams remaining for
of means offense okay
offense score
equals to NP Dot
round
e f d f
then oh
team
that's equals to X
then
home
team
fans
score
mean
that's DF
and DF again
that should be
team
and offense
of course
request to PD dot data frames
he should be Capital data
frame
and
team
World Cup 2022
comma
offensive score
then
offense
score
Dot
sort
values
yes
it's just code
okay
then
ends
scores
Dot
index
plus equals to one
okay then offense
scores
so let's see the offensive score for the
four team Argentina France Morocco and
Croatia who has the like maximum
so like team
Argentina has the maximum offensive
score and then France with 87 then
Morocco 82.99 and Croatia
okay
so now we will see
the team who scored goal how many goals
they scored in home the away the total
goal scored like considered goal in home
and conceded goals away
and the total considered goals okay and
the ratio
so this is a like long quote so I will
get back to you
so let's see so as you can see the
France has 447
scored goals at home and this score
goals away in 14 okay then the gold
ratio is 2.86 something
okay
and the Argentina is like the 379 and
Croatia and Morocco okay so the next we
will discuss offensive strength versus
goal scored okay what are the offensive
strengths of the particular team versus
gold score
so now we will do offense stance versus
gold score okay for that I will write
offense
players
versus goal
good
okay
so for that I have learned of fans
course
dot merge
and goals
on
team
I will write
team
comma
like
Francisco
come on
total
or
goals
and I will copy something
yeah
so now I will write offense
players
versus
goals
scored
dot index
plus equals to 1.
okay
then I have to write here of fans
players
versus
goals
code
okay
yeah so you can see
the offensive score of France
and the total goal scored 461 and the
total score goes versus goalkeeper score
okay goal scored so this is 5.27 and
5203 and this is Argentina Morocco and
Croatia okay
so this is based on total goal scored
the ranking 461 387 350 and 309. okay so
we will see the graph for the same
so then I will write PLT dot figure
then
bigger size
should be
11 comma seven
API
equals to 90.
okay then ax equals to SNS Dot
bar plot
then data
equals to
offense
pairs
versus
goals
scored
comma x equals to
team
y equals to
Tal
score
total scored uh
I will write a total score goals
slash GK Square
okay
so I will write here ax dot bar
table
ax Dot
container
zero
then PLT Dot X label
team
then PLT
dot y label
ratio
then
PLT dot title
okay
then teams
best
CSU
calls slash
bands
score
okay
so as soon as per plot there is one
error
Network
okay
so that is code
goals
slash okay gk's capital
is small
you can see here
okay
yeah
so you can see the France Argentina
Morocco and the Croatia team's best
ratio goes versus offense ratio
okay
now we will see the goalkeeper score
okay so the code is same so I will copy
and
paste it here
okay this is the goalkeeper's code like
France has the best goalkeeper
okay as per the data okay Argentina has
like 81
and Croatia 80 and Morocco is 77.
so
we will see the goalkeeper
like versus goals considered how many he
gold considered okay
so for that you can see like
total considered goal like Morocco as a
total consider goal and uh gold ratio
1.5
then Argentina France and Croatia
okay
so let's have a like graph
so I will copy it like same mostly same
so I will paste it here
yeah so you can see Team best ratio
considered gold versus gks score so
crochet is a good one and the France
so after that
what we will do we will uh see the
team's longest win history okay this
team has the longest win streak okay
so
for that
or that
I have created one data frame and for t
mean each World Cup 2022
so there is home team which is Steam and
there is away team okay and in respect
of winds
we are declaring this streak okay
if a home team result equals to equals
to win so it will be one streak okay
like that we are calculating this tree
okay so press enter
like Morocco has this streak of 11
France 10 Argentina nine and five
Croatia okay so let's create the graph
for the same
regard size equals to
11 comma seven
comma DPI equals to 90.
okay then ax equals to
SNS Dot
bar plot
then data
pursue
streaks
then like 10
x equals to
team okay
comma y equals to streak
okay
so ax dot bar
like level
then ax Dot
containers
then
zero
PLT Dot
X label
team
and PLT dot y label
streak
okay then PLT dot title teams
longest
win streak
okay
so let's see
so as you can see in the graph Morocco
first France second Argentina third and
Croatia 5. okay at the fourth location
so we will see like
win or lose of a way better team Rank
and like home better team rank what is
the kind of you know the results
okay win percentage we will see
like
if you will play in home how much the
win percentage is
okay then we will see the waving
percentage
okay so we are seeing the better team
win percentage
so let's see
what can I do
so this is the home tea better rank
okay
so
this is the win percentage if you will
be in home
so it will be 70 chance or 71 chance you
will win
okay
if you are not playing in Hope
so it is just 37 percent
chances to win
okay then let's make the figure
size equals to
11.
comma 7
okay go on DPI equals to 90.
okay ax equals to
SNS dot bar plot
okay
data
let's do better
team
win
percentage
okay uh you can see
percent
comma X
equals to better
team
when
percent
Dot
index
comma y equals to
one percent
then ax dot bar
level
x dot
containers
elt dot X label
is
t
better
okay then PLT dot y label
is
one percent
PLT Dot
title
should be
team win
percentage
okay
so this is the graph we will
in home like 70 chance and Away 37 and
the total is 61. okay
quickly what we gonna do is we will see
the rank of the team
okay these four teams rank
and not in FIFA World Cup like in
current
with all the in the current world okay
you can say and we will see the rate of
defense for the particular teams and we
will see rate of attack for the
particular teams Midfield strength and
uh like okay at the end what we will do
we will see the
winning percentage of the particular
team who can win after that we will
create a model and we will predict who
can we win
okay
so
okay so let's quickly do let's see the
rank of the teams and so on so on
okay
so
we'll do
so we'll do here for the rank of the
team
okay
we'll see like in current scenario like
France is in third not in World Cup
Qatar 2022 okay in World Cup they are
like at the same stage okay this is all
about the world
okay ranking throughout the world
okay
let's see the goalkeeper score
so
France is having the best goalkeeper
score of 54 percent then Argentina
Croatia and Morocco means like France
has the higher chances to win but this
is a game so it's not sure who will win
and who will not okay it is a sport
anyways we'll see the goalkeeper score
of graph
why I'm showing you like in a fast way
because it is so easy we did it already
okay
this is the goalkeeper score graph
and we'll see the rate of Defense whose
defense is good
France defense is good so there is
another point
like France can win
okay
so let's have a
figure
so this is the strongest defense having
France is having strongest defend
Argentina than Croatia
okay
then we'll see the rate of attack
team attack strength Argentina is having
the best rate of attack than France then
Morocco then Croatia
okay
let's see
so this is the attack score okay like
France is like Argentina is having the
best attack score
for a while in these four teams okay
let's see the Miss Midfield this time
Midfield strength so for that
see the France is having still you can
see France is
having the best Midfield score and take
a following by Argentina
let's see the graph
for the same
yeah so France
okay
so now we have seen all the offenses to
attack score best attack score best
goalkeeper best defense best Midfield
so
okay so let's see
who has the higher chances to win
okay the team's highest chances to win
okay but again this is just a prediction
because it is a machine
okay after that we will create a model
and we'll do so so
let's see the winning percentage
for the particular team it will be like
based on
like home wins home draws home losses
and so on with the things okay so
so this is
like it is based on home win like how
much time the team wins or team draw
team lose okay home lose home draw it is
based on this then we will calculate the
aveen okay
so using a wave in home losses away
losses away draws home draws and using
this thing
we are getting the
chances of
so like Vince Vince is not defined
okay it's friends
but don't know like fins
okay
when that is Vince those letters loses
okay
this is not defined okay
so let me check
so issue has been resolved so you can
see the home win 130 145 124 and 92 and
this is the winning percentage okay so
based on these so we will see the graph
so I will write PLT dot figure
yeah then figure size should be
yes I should be
the same
11 comma seven
okay
comma DPI
equals to 90.
okay then ax
equals to SNS
Dot
bar plot
data
equals to when
let's go draw
underscore lost
10
comma x equals to
question
team
comma y
question
okay
then PLT Dot X level
equals to
aim
PLT dot y label equals to
our
PLT
dot title
themes with
highest winning
percentage
okay
so let's see the the team with highest
winning percentage so as you can see it
is Argentina then France then Morocco
then Croatia okay so why
the percentage is not coming up
here here
let's see
score
winning which is not taking that
I don't know it is y naught is taking
winning percent
no
something is like there okay no issues
so Argentina chances is 68 and then
France is 65 and this Morocco and
Croatia okay then through Croatia
so now what we will do now we will
create our model linear model okay then
we will uh some do some simulations then
we will do some train test split
function
we will see the ROC curve we will see
Roc AUC curve and
we will see the pipeline we will see
polynomial feature so many things to go
okay
so
let's start then
so I will write here from sqlarn
near
model okay
then I will add from SK learn
Escalon
import
and symbol
from sqln
dot model selection
okay
phone
test
split
from
sqln Dot
Matrix
import
confusion Matrix
Roc curve
and Roc AUC
curve
okay
issu score
okay then from sqlan
dot pipeline
for
pipeline
okay so then last from Escalon
Dot pre-processing
port
polynomial
features
okay
but everything is imported that we will
write
like we will do some tree entice split
like training we have to uh like
split the training and data and testing
design okay
so
there's a huge
code behind that
so as you can see we have declared the
XY for retaining and testing average
difference Point difference
and who is one okay so there is Extreme
X test whiten and Y test equal to
interest split so test size should be
0.2 0.2 means 20 okay 80 is training 20
is for testing
so here we will using logistic
regression okay for the linear model
logistic regression okay
so feature at the for the features we
using polynomial features okay degree
equals to two
and the model the pipeline you say you
can see the polynomial feature is equal
to features and the logistic regression
okay so this is the figures
these for the figures so
now you will see AOC score is this so
now you will see the graph
so the graph is like this much okay
so
so the idea is to separate the
performance of each team as home or away
okay so I will write a word
cup
rankings
home
assume
were
up
rankings
home
Dot
Group by
home team
or mean
World Cup
Kings
away
version
World Cup
rankings
away
Dot
Group by
way
team
so we will import
some to show taskbar and all
ROM
tqdm
import
tqdm
okay
and simulation
of winners
because you there is a list
okay
then what we'll do simulations
the results
of nurse
virtual list
stimulation
results
semi-final
because we are checking for the same
final and the final okay because we'll
list
emulation
of EF of semi-final
it was a list
okay
so
okay
average rank equals to home rank Plus
opposition rank
okay
remove this
okay
so there is one error let me fix it and
get back to you
yeah so now it is working so these are
the thousand you know simulations
so here we have given the number of
simulations to thousand
so till then what we will do we will
write
the code for the graph
okay so here I will write from
collections
okay import
ant
okay then from matplotlib
or
bigger
the last result
equals to
simulation
results
then semi-final
s comma
simulation
winners
for I
and last
results
equals to counter
of I
Dot
common
okay
so
comma y
equals to zip
results
okay
then
bigger
ax
equals to
PLT
Dot subplots
then figure size should be
15 comma 8.
okay
and ax dot per h
then X comma y
okay then ax dot set
y label
y label
and
team
if I equals to equals to simulation
results
semi-final
okay
then ax dot set
title
my final
results
if a World Cup
two zero two two
okay
if I
question simulation
results simulation winners
okay
peanuts
then
I'll copy from here itself
okay it is the
final
result FIFA World Cup 2022
okay
then PLT dot show
I don't think so it will run because
it's like three percent
but our simulations is going on
okay let's see it is running or not
it is not running
so let's say fire spinner
okay
yeah
so as you can see like from Morocco and
France France is winning
Russia Argentina
uh crochet is winning
and at the final
the France is winning
from Croatia and for the third is
Argentina Morocco and Morocco is winning
okay
so these are from the this simulation we
have done
okay there there are number of
simulation is still coming so maybe the
result will change
okay let me write code for the graph
and we will run it again import
X till then simulation is working
SNS
then sns.set
theme
Style
equals to White grid
okay
Stan
sns.set
RC equals to
figure
dot figure size
should be
like
14
comma 10
I will draw a nested bar plot okay by T
for the same final and the final okay so
g equals to
SNS dot bar plot
then data equals to DF
underscore results
then X
question
team
comma y equals to the probability
of winning
then here equals to
tap
ER
equals to sum
comma p
l a t t e palette equals to
dark
then Alpha
equals to 0.6
okay let me run it
okay
so the prop
e should be capital
yeah
so as you can see the France is winning
the World Cup
of the 2022 and France is a good team
though
Argentina is coming third and Morocco
fourth
see the simulation changes and the
result changes so again I will run this
so as you can see
the Morocco and the crochet the France
is winning
okay
yes so France first Croatia second
Argentina third and Morocco fourth as
per the
this prediction okay our prediction
like there is number of like 1000
simulation which is done
for the prediction I am not saying okay
France will win at any cost
but
there might be chance
like they will win they can win from the
pre from the previous data okay
so
let's come to the realistic perspective
okay so now from a realistic perspective
it is much harder to find a team to bet
on okay even though historical and the
team data points to France as a clear
favorite This World Cup has been like
nothing short of a roller coaster of the
emotions Croatia has been absolutely
Relentless thanks for their
Stellar Midfield
and ability to grind out the games with
the rigid defense
Morocco is a defense judgment yet to
concede a goal from an opponent in the
tournament France is poised to come out
on the top with the most stacked Squad
in the competition and
with Argentina reading on Messi's form
to the semi-finals with the most people
inching toward mbappe taking the cup
once again do not be a surprise if
Argentina find its way to the top
considering the form they have been
through
for the past years but if there is
anything the World Cup has shown it is a
degree of arsenity that each provides so
the best we can hope for the last few
matches to be as good as if not better
than the preceding games
which have been delivering on all the
fronts after four years of the waiting
since the last World Cup
okay guys so I hope you guys must have
have understood how you can predict the
World Cup winner as per the data if you
have any queries you can ask in the
comment section below our team will
respond to you as soon as possible don't
forget to check the course link from the
description box below or the data set
link and if you wanted this full code
so you can comment for the same thank
you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please give like to
this video please subscribe to our
YouTube channel and till then thank you
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here